how many held power for 10 years
and then took power the next Supreme
leader who is still the leader today for
over 30 years who is he
well he was one of the this is
one day perhaps no well they they
hesitated to use the term Imam for him
but in any other respect he was given
all of that adulation yes that they did
to how many he is the guardian jurist
that's what's important because the
guardian jurist in the constitution of
the Islamic Republic is an authority
that is above this state
he is not
elected quote unquote because
this is a Divine Authority although he
has been designated by the group of
determined mullahs like himself
and uh
he has the full power over all
uh
institutions of the state
the Army the media
the economy every aspect of the acts
like you show
it's like this authoritarian Authority
did that gradually develop or was that
very early on well that's part of the
Constitution of the Islamic Republic
the first constitution
the first draft of the Constitution did
not have the authority of the Guardian
Judas but then it was added by
Khomeini and his supporters are there
actual in the Constitution any limits to
his power
yes there is a council of the experts so
to say
that would
remove him from Power I think
theoretically
but there is so much
restrictions to that that I don't think
it would have ever happened in reality
in this case at least but in terms of
executive to make decisions and all that
kind of stuff does he need to check with
anybody no
boy he does check
with his own advisors but he's he
doesn't have any he doesn't have any
constitutional obligation to check on
the decisions that he's making
so that's the supreme leader but there's
been presidents yes and what's the role
of the president the president in a
sense is the executive power
under the Islamic Republic there are
three heads of
powers
the the president that presumably has
the executive power
there is the head of the judiciary
and there is the head of the
uh the speaker of the parliament much
less
which is the uh the legislative so the
legislative
Judiciary and executive
who is not a president
is the uh the head of the Executive
above them
is the supreme leader or the guardian
jurist can you give me some insight
because I especially
I'm not exactly sure why but uh the
president Ahmadinejad
somebody I'm as an American really
familiar with why is that exactly but
why was why was the president the
public-facing person to the world versus
the supreme leader uh is that just an
accident of a particular humans involved
or is this by Design no because the
supreme leader tries to keep himself out
of
issues of everyday politics supposedly
yeah but therefore he is not coming to
United Nations to give a speech during
the uh session uh but Mr ahmadines at
the time was the president
uh would come and make outrageous
statements that's why you probably know
something about him so all of them make
public statements but he had a
proclivity for outrageous statements
and it does all kinds of things he makes
all kinds of statements but he is
somewhat above the everyday politics in
theory
but of course he's pulling all the
strings with without doubt in every last
respect and it seems that you were asked
I thought you're going to ask me this
question almost without a an exception
since the Inception of the Islamic
Republic in 1979
up to the last of the presidents of the
Islamic Republic Rouhani before the guy
that is last year or a year and a half
ago was in a phony election uh got into
the position of the president
all of them has a long list
all of them eventually fell out with the
regime mm-hmm so there is no president
except perhaps to some extent Drew honey
but wait and see what is going to happen
to him but prior to him all of them
including Ahmadinejad fell out with the
regime with the current regime in Iraq
who's Johan he was officially president
for eight years yeah prior to raisy
Ibrahimovic the 221 the year what you're
saying is a phony election yesterday
what happened
because the process of actually
candidacy
for presidency is completely controlled
by a a cancer that is under the control
of the uh supreme leader so they have to
approve who is going to be the candidate
so why does everybody can enter and say
I would like to be a candidate so did
Rouhani follow out of favor you're
saying there's something yeah well he is
kind of out of favor now because he was
more moderate than this this most recent
regime but the point is that
if you look this is something almost
institutional cons constitutional to the
regime this is the regime that rejects
all of the executive powers
because it's
because the division between the supreme
authority as this place of a supreme
authority versus the presidency has
problematic
uh it is as if there would be a
a a supreme leader in the United States
above all these three sources of power
I mean that's the kind of any view that
we can see in today's Iran and of course
he is at the focus of all the criticism
that he receives from the demonstrators
in today's Iran